♪ ♪
>> Greg: LAST WEEKEND'S
VIOLENT CRIME WAVE IN CHICAGO
LEFT 12 PEOPLE DEAD AND 70 SHOT,
THE CITY'S TOP COP IS CALLING
OUT THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
BLAMING THE COURTS FOR THE CRIME
SPREE.
>> WE ARE ARRESTING VIOLENT
OFFENDERS, THE COURTS ARE
RELEASING THESE PEOPLE BACK INTO
COMMUNITIES, AND OVER 90 PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH MURDER HAVE BEEN
RELEASED, THAT SHOULD BE A
HEADLINE IN THIS CITY IT'S NOT.
SO BE ADVERSARIAL TO THE COURTS,
ASK WHAT THE COURTS CAN DO
DIFFERENT RATHER THAN RELEASE
VIOLENT PEOPLE BACK TO THESE
COMMUNITIES TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT OF LAWLESSNESS.
>> Greg: IT'S SAD THAT COMMON
SENSE IS SEEN AS REFRESHING.
A FORMER DEMOCRATIC SENATOR FROM
CALIFORNIA BECOMING THE LATEST
VICTIM OF A NATIONWIDE SPIKE IN
VIOLENT CRIME, BARBARA BOXER
REVEALING SHE WAS ATTACKED IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT.
>> I TRIED TO CROSS THE STREET
AND GET AWAY AND HE SLAMMED ME
ON THE BACK AND REACHED ACROSS
ME, HE WAS BEHIND ME AND GRABBED
MY CELL PHONE OUT OF MY HAND AND
I JUST SAID, HOW CAN YOU DO THIS
TO A GRANDMOTHER, WHY ARE YOU
DOING THIS?
HE COULD CARE LESS AND GOT IN
THE CAR AND SPED AWAY.
THREE A CONSERVATIVE IS A
LIBERAL MUGGED BY REALITY.
ACCUSED KILLERS HAVE BEEN LET GO
BY THE COURTS, IS IT POSSIBLE TO
DO, LIKE, A CLASS ACTION SUIT OF
VICTIMS FAMILIES AGAINST THE
CITY?
IT SEEMS LIKE POLITICIANS ARE
ONLY SCARED OF LAWYERS.
>> Geraldo: I THINK IT'S AN
EXCELLENT IDEA, IT'S
IMPRACTICAL.
FIRST OF ALL, SUPERINTENDENT
BROWN IS A GREAT GUY BUT HE IS
TRANSFERRING ALL THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE COURTS AND
THE PROSECUTORS AND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT'S WOEFULLY
UNDERMANNED AND REALLY HAS TO
STEP UP.
WHEN YOU HAVE THERE IS THE BLOOD
FLOWING IN THE STREETS AND 12
DEAD THIS WEEKEND, THERE WERE 12
LAST WEEKEND, 17 THE WEEKEND
BEFORE THAT, IT'S SO MUCH BIGGER
THAN THE 90 MURDERERS WHO ARE
RELEASED ALTHOUGH THAT IS PART
OF THE PROBLEM AND YOU HAVE A
SITUATION HERE WHERE WE ARE
LOSING AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF
YOUNG LACHMAN AND NOBODY CARES
ABOUT IT UNLESS THERE'S A WHITE
COP INVOLVED.
IT IS HORRIFIC WHAT'S HAPPENING,
THIS IS THE CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE
OF OUR TIME.
THERE IS A GHETTO CIVIL WAR
GOING ON, THEY ARE FIGHTING OVER
TURF AND FIRING INTO CROWDS
WILLY-NILLY AS IT THAT WAS A
SIGN OF MACHO, SHOOT UP A
BARBECUE AND KILL A 6-YEAR-OLD.
I THINK THE FACT THAT THIS IS
NOT THE FRONT PAGE STORY COAST
TO TO ME FILLS YOU WITH DISMAY.
>> Greg: I AGREE, WE SAY THAT
GUN VIOLENCE IS A NATIONAL
PROBLEM BUT POLICING IS LOCAL,
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF CRIME
GOING ON, YOU SEE BARBARA BOXER,
SHE'S 80.
NOT THAT THERE'S HONOR AMONG
MUGGERS AND THIEVES AND JUNKIES
BUT GENERALLY THEY DON'T REALLY
GO AND BEAT THE CRAP OUT OF OLD
LADIES AND NOW THAT'S EVERYDAY.
>> Dagen: IT IS EVERY DAY AND
WHEN YOU READ THE STORY, WHETHER
IT'S IN NEW YORK OR SAN
FRANCISCO, IT'S VERY CLEAR IF
YOU READ THE NEWSPAPER THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THROWN IN JAIL
YEARS AGO AND STAYED THERE ABOUT
BECAUSE OF THIS REVOLVING DOOR
WHETHER IT'S FROM BAIL REFORM,
WHETHER IT IS LIBERAL
PROSECUTORS, THEY ARE NOT KEPT
IN JAIL.
IF ANYBODY'S PICKED UP HERE IN
NEW YORK, JUST FOR SIMPLE
ASSAULT THEY ARE RIGHT BACK ON
THE STREET IMMEDIATELY AND THIS
IS A UNIQUE KIND OF EVIL AND
COWARDICE, ATTACKING ELDERLY
PEOPLE THAT REALLY QUICKLY I
WANT TO POINT OUT, I HAVE
MENTIONED THIS ON THE SHOW
BEFORE, BUT THERE WERE TWO
ELDERLY ASIAN WOMEN WHO WERE
STABBED IN SAN FRANCISCO BY A
MAN NAMED PATRICK THOMPSON AND
THE KNIFE WAS AS LONG AS THE ARM
OF ONE OF THESE ELDERLY ASIAN
WOMEN AND THE HANDLE BROKE OFF
AND THE SERRATED KNIFE WAS STUCK
INSIDE OF HER.
WHERE DID HE COME FROM?
HE HAD A BACKGROUND INCLUDING
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON AND
HE ACTUALLY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
IN JAIL FOR LIFE AND HE WAS
RELEASED ON A MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION.
AND NOW HE IS BEING PROSECUTED
BUT THESE PEOPLE ARE EVERYWHERE
AND NOBODY CARES ABOUT THE
VICTIMS.
>> Greg: BUT THANK GOD WE GOT
THAT GUY IN THE VIKING HAT.
DO YOU THINK CNN AND THE
DEMOCRATS WOULD PAY MORE
ATTENTION IF WE POINTED OUT THAT
THE CRIMINALS ARE PROBABLY NOT
VACCINATED?
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF NOT
VACCINATED, GERALDO, I HAD TO
FACT-CHECK YOU ON THEN THE LAST
SEGMENT, 900% INCREASE IN COVID
CASES IN THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY
SECTOR AND 8% POSITIVITY RATE IN
THE DETAINMENT FACILITIES.
NEW YORK CITY CLOSE DOWN AT 3%,
THIS IS 8% SO YOU WERE WRONG, I
WILL EXPECT AN APOLOGY IN THE
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
JIM FOX'S THE VILLAIN IN
CHICAGO, SHE IS THE D.A., SHE
HAS SEVEN TO MAKE 700 LAWYERS
UNDER HER TUTELAGE, RAN ON THIS
ANTI-COP PLATFORM, EVERYBODY
GETS OUT, GEORGE SOROS FUNDED
HER SUPER PAC.
YOU ASK WHY, WELL, THEY VOTED
FOR HER.
SO AT A CERTAIN POINT YOU HAVE
TO SAY, CHICAGO, I FEEL SORRY
FOR YOU BUT YOU'RE PUTTING
PEOPLE IN OFFICE THAT ARE
RAISING BODY COUNTS.
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE SUPPOSED TO WORK
TOGETHER BUT IF GEORGE SOROS
KEEPS FINDING THESE RADICAL
DAs THAT WON'T WORK WITH
POLICE DEPARTMENTS TO KEY PEOPLE
BEHIND BARS, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
MORE CHICAGO'S.
>> Greg: IT'S FUNNY, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, THE MAYOR OF
CHICAGO WAS AN OLD WHITE DUDE,
WOULDN'T YOU BE KIND OF SUSPECT
OF WHETHER OR NOT HE REALLY
CARES ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE CLASS
FOR THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD THINK
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF CASUALTIES,
THESE ARE BLACK AND BROWN
BODIES.
>> Dana: THE ISSUE ON THE
PROSECUTOR DOESN'T GET AS MUCH
ATTENTION AS THE POLICE AS YOU
BUT IT SHOULD.
THEY WON'T LISTEN TO US BUT WILL
THEY LISTEN TO THE POLICE CHIEF?
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST THE ONE IN
CHICAGO, IT'S THE ONE IN D.C.
AND IN ST. LOUIS AND IN LOS
ANGELES SO YOU HAVE ALL OF THAT,
THE 1994 REPUBLICAN WAVE WAS
PARTLY ABOUT CRIME AND MANY
OTHER THINGS AS WELL, THAT
WASN'T JUST IN CONGRESS, THAT
WAS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS SO DO YOUR POINT IF
YOU ARE ELECTING THESE TYPES OF
PEOPLE THAT'S THE KIND OF
RESULTS ARE GOING TO GET BUT
THERE COULD BE AN EVEN BIGGER
WAY OF HAPPENING IN 2022.
>> Geraldo: FROM THE TITLE 42,
PEOPLE WHO ARE INFECTED WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS ARE TURNED BACK AT
THE BORDER